this is a quick demonstration of how to
easily select a chromosome region while
using ncbi's genome data viewer or gdb
I'll start on the gdv home page with
human selected but this capability is
available for all organisms that have
completely assembled chromosomes I'll
open the viewers display by clicking on
browse genome for the latest assembly
grch38 by default all of chromosome 1 is
displayed you can change chromosomes in
the ideogram view
or in the pulldown menu above the
chromosome region selector which is the
focus of this video and if you suddenly
remember that you really wanted the
previous assembly you can change that
here as well for a few organisms you'll
see this cytogenetic banding if you want
to view the q24 region for example
simply click inside the region to select
it and the display below zooms to that
region of course you can click and drag
to select any part of the chromosome and
then click and drag the ends of the
selection window to resize it for those
organisms curated by the genome
reference consortium human Mouse
zebrafish and chicken curation regions
like patches are annotated under the
chromosome hover over a marked region to
get more information then in the pop up
you can click on the region name to zoom
to that region or if you click on the
refseq for this patch the graphical view
opens that patch scaffold this NW
accession clicking on the GenBank
accession would open that record in
another browser window this tool also
presents green arrowheads for search
results for example a search for
diabetes finds two genes on chromosome 1
if you want to then remove these green
arrow heads use reset off near the top
of the page and don't forget other
useful actions you can share the view
you've created with the share this page
link you can download a PDF or vector
graphic file from the download menu
and finally we'd love to hear your
feedback in questions